each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay thank you very much for coming
today we're very pleased to have Brent
Waters speaking to us on unbounded hyb
and a B E and Brent will be receiving a
faculty fellowship today so
congratulations by event and we're very
pleased to have you here okay great
thanks guys okay so I see a lot of
people guess this is a point of
convergence over the summers I see a lot
of people I know from different places
okay so today I'm gonna give a guess
there's gonna be a little more on the
technical side of funk of this
functional encryption domain I'm gonna
talk about unbounded a hierarchical
identity based encryption and attribute
based encryption and I'll discuss what I
mean by unbounded soon and this is joint
work with my student Allison okay so
just to put this give a couple big
picture slides before you start talk
about the technical details to put this
in context one you know of course grand
notion that that's in cryptography has
been the advent of public key
cryptography where if Bob wants to send
a message let's say to Sarah over here
he doesn't need to have an operation
secret key was Sarah and instead he what
he can do is he can use her public key
to encrypt the message for her and then
send it on over to her and then she can
use her secret key to decrypt so I'm
sure everyone here is pretty familiar
with this notion ever along with this
great advant though has become too
ingrained notions in our head first one
is that when I'm encrypting to someone
I'm usually targeting a particular
receiver that is I'm sending to you or
you know I have someone particular in my
mind I'm sending and the second one is
that decryption is an all-or-nothing
process as I either decrypt the message
and learn everything about it or I don't
learn anything at all and maybe instead
we want to instead we want to learn some
type of function or partial view of the
message depending on what our
credentials are okay so the problems
with this are let's imagine Bob is in a
different scenario what he isn't saying
okay I just want to encrypted this user
Sarah anymore what he what he wants to
do is he's thinking of sharing
information let's say in the LAPD with
everyone who's in internal affairs or
who's an undercover officer and the
Central Division now when he's thinking
of him from sharing information this way
he runs into a few problems first of all
how does he figure out everyone who
matches this like how does he knew like
he has to have some process for
numerating one i'm also even allowed to
know everyone that matches this like
maybe it's not a good idea to be able to
enumerate all in to cover officers you
know might sort of defeat the attribute
a second what what if someone joins the
system later I you know I want to clip
to everyone who you know who has and
will match this profile but I don't know
what the future holds like I don't know
who's gonna you know be here in the
summer and next summer at Microsoft and
what instead if we want to have a
process view of the data so instead of
like in the past what we had that
usually do is how to UM transform you
know like somehow engineer our way
between how we think of data and this
mechanism for public key encryption
which could be a messy thing and there
might not be solutions in in all these
cases and so what the vision of
functional encryption does is instead of
trying to just bridge this gap with
engineering I want to be able to when I
think of sharing information in a
certain way I want to be able to express
this or embed this in the encryption
system itself okay
so this is this is gonna like I decided
to throw these couple I can't borrow
some of Alison's slide and decide to
throw in these things to try to give
maybe the big picture of what we're
looking at that will hopefully you know
motivate some of the things we're
working on okay so today what I'm going
to do is I'm going to talk about two
specific
primitives within this so this
functional encryption idea is this big
umbrella and you know can cover a lot of
different things and here what I'm going
to really do is talk about like to two
particular problems like two particular
specific things a tree based encryption
and HIV so let's take a look at
hierarchical identity based encryption
just to get a sense how many people are
familiar with this most most people in
the room okay um okay so the idea of
most most people familiar with identity
based encryption I mean I assume it's a
suit suit okay so so identity based
encryption is where when I
encrypt the message I don't need to look
up I can just describe it you know I had
this I can just describe it with your
name or your identity hierarchical I bet
Denning based encryption is can be
thought of some of it as a
generalization of this where the name
covector of names like for example you
might think of a hierarchy like on
internet
edu that you Texas sorry I guess it's
the opposite direction the way the
internet puts it it's edu : you Texas
clone CS : be waters and identity a the
idea of hierarchical ibe is let's say
some user there could be some masked
authority who generates these keys way
up there that's not even the picture and
let's say there's some user like Alyce
here who has the edu one and she and
what she could do is well she can use it
to decrypt things - edu but she can also
create keys further on down the line
maybe Stanford's over here and you Texas
is ID 2 Prime and then we can go on down
to CS and and delegate on down further
hopefully the benefit being that like
you know it's easier for let's say this
guy to know which departments I'm
University of Texas has as opposed to
some one way up higher on the chain okay
so since most the so it's good that
there's become a brief introduction here
okay so Alice can have a key and she can
autonomously create these on private key
she doesn't need to go back up to the
authority okay so let me just briefly go
through HIV and anyone should stop me if
they are not you know I'm gonna go
through this a little quickly since I
assume there's some familiarity with it
but please stop me if there's a point of
confused confusion here okay so there's
gonna be a set up algorithm where this
let's say Authority will generate the
public parameters and also generate a
master secret key pair all right okay
then there's going to be an encryption
algorithm where I'm going to want to
encrypt the message m use these public
parameters and describe how I'm
encrypting it by this vector of
identities
so let's say I'm encrypting I'll just
keep on using the same example I mean
crypting again - like edu I'm see as I
always do it backwards edu you text to
CS be waters okay and and then there's a
key generation process which the
master authority during its a private
key for perhaps a different identity
vector I so again with these higher cut
ones and it'll like create the secret
key for this and then finally this um so
that's to get it from the mast Authority
but also if I if I'm somewhere on this
chain like let's say in Kristen's groups
you might want to delegate on down
she'll execute this algorithm which she
can take her secret key and create one
sort of lower on the hierarchy below
that okay and then finally there's gonna
be Krypton algorithm where if I have a
private key so let's say if if a
ciphertext was encrypted for an identity
vector let's call X and I have a private
key for identity vector Y if Y is a
prefix of X I can decrypt let's assume
they do for Dow you could you could have
systems where you couldn't differentiate
between them but let's just let's just
assume we kind of let's just assume we
require that they have the same
distribution fair enough I mean yeah
okay but yeah in practically you can get
you can actually gain some efficiency in
practice by relaxing this a little bit
but yeah look let's assume that's the
case okay and one of the goals with with
hierarchical identity based encryption
is that you get this flexibility first
of all you users can enter at any level
and you can sort of get your key from
the immediate supervisor let's say if
I'm Kristen hire someone which
apparently she has done for this summer
you know we doesn't need to like call up
Bill Gates a Steve Ballmer or something
and not that that would literally happen
but you know she she you know she can
autonomously make decisions like you
know she has this local view within our
group and you know it's probably the
case that like you know like the people
way up at Microsoft I'm sure they do
care about you but they probably don't
rape Rob Lee don't they care about you
but they probably aren't knowledgeable
about you and it's much better if she
can make these local decisions and we
can encrypt to any ID string okay and
and it's even less likely that someone
at the dot-com domain knows about your
you know some employment okay so so nhip
systems or sorry what we have is we can
have an exponential size identity sort
of horizontally yeah and what I mean by
this is that at each level the string
can be of any length I mean just using
collision resistant hash functions we
can make this string of any length but
one question I'm gonna ask here is using
criticism what about vertical growth
like how many levels how many levels do
I want to be able to go down and so what
we have is we've so let's say what we've
had in previous systems is that we
always had to when we set up the system
we had to set up the depth of the
hierarchy like you know when we publish
the public parameters we had to say well
this is going to go to depth seven this
is going to go to depth three we had to
kind of pick something ahead of time and
the reason we don't just pick like Oh
depth ten billion or something is that
the size of the parameters tends to
scale linearly with the depth and so we
kind of end up in this kind of funny
situation where you have to take this
guess ahead of time and if you you know
if you're overly conservative you might
pay a lot in terms of performance and
however if you're if you're if you want
to really you know you want to keep
things small keep things compact it
might turn out that someone needs to go
down to certain depth and you cut them
off earlier and that could be a problem
we'll see towards the end of the talk
like well an HIV somebody could say well
maybe like twenty is good enough for all
applications but an attribute based
encryption this sort of a pedagogical we
spend most the time technical time on
HIV but an attribute based encryption I
think this scenario becomes more
motivating where instead of bounding
like a depth u bounding the number of
attributes you can use and that that
that's probably um so I'll just remark
even though I'm going to talk about HIV
I'll kind of remark that you know
perhaps the stronger motivation comes
from the attribute based encryption for
those of you have heard of it I'll talk
but also so we will kind of learn but
the main technical things we can learn
in the HIV world it's a little simpler
so I'm going to focus focus on that
but just kind of keep in mind this is
where we eventually go to okay so so but
if we form previous systems we always
had to have this bound of the depth for
two different reasons um the first one
we which we used to have was a security
degradation where the where we used to
have these partitioning improves for
security and for adaptive security uh we
just had an exponential loss and the
depth of the hierarchy how many people
like I don't mean to make this into a
quiz or anything how many people kind of
heard of heard of this problem or kind
of maybe okay so yeah so like you know
if I want to go the depth D
I usually had like if there are Q
queries you said I got to use the
whiteboard right yeah so later I'm gonna
want to just move that is that a doable
thing so if we had like Q queries and we
had let's say depth let's say D was our
depth this the security loss and all
these reductions was like yet you lost
this Q to the D factor so you know if
you went to depth six okay so this is
exponential in the depth D so this was
not such a such a good thing but
actually it do turn out that there were
techniques Imfurst by Craig Gentry and
say hello be using one thing and then
might myself using something called dual
system encryption that actually got
around this problem so we just ended up
with one over to you and you know we
didn't need to worry about this depth D
factor okay but even with this private
key queries so so an attacker can make
queries to key gen and to delegate to
key gen and to delegate um so you know
if he made yeah so but this was for
adaptive security by the way if we if we
kind of made this sort of false
assumption that obviously tells you
which thing he's taking ahead of time
it's tight but tight for a kind of false
reason
Oh genius
um but both like that yeah if you and it
wasn't just so I have this is the first
one but then Alison I had some other
ones along these lines
there are change I mean there are
different systems technically although
they clearly have inspiration from it
wasn't like we just wipe the board clean
but yeah we needed to change the system
- yeah I can talk about that offline its
kind of its kind of you know it's sort
of it's almost like the same system you
can prove it's secure in a few different
ways but not quite the same okay but
even if we believe the Selective model
and now that we do have these proofs we
have another problem which is that the
parameter size on like I was saying
earlier does dictate how far we can go
down and we're kind of if you think
you're trying to export an AP look let's
pretend you know we're cryptographers
but we're trying to export this API to
some systems person they have to sort of
make this operate they have to make this
guess about how you know how big your
system is gonna be how deep it's going
to be or in the case of a B how many
attributes you're going to use and it'd
be better not to force them to make this
guess right because you know they they
have this trade-off and you know if they
try if they want to help performance
they're going to have to go one way and
however they go too far you know the
system won't work so in all pretty much
in all previous constructions I should
say in the standard model with random
Oracle's you can play a few tricks like
it you know it had these it had these um
limitations and also there's this lot of
stuff and so the lot of stuff you know
had some neat innovations but really it
follows kind of high-level comment well
stuff like I mean you have all this
fancy lab stuff going around but at the
commenter level it's really the same as
the old pairing based constructions and
and so it has the same limitations okay
so I want to do something a little
experimental it's okay I'm under control
hey yeah and I want to how do we raise
the board there's a presumably uh a
button oh did I just so
this is so revolutionary we don't know
how to
oh boy okay so I might ask you to lower
it again Josh yeah well I mean it's a
whole new button in this okay so we'll
we'll actually see how this then I try
something a little experimental here and
uh oh boy
and we can see if it was a good idea at
the end of the day okay but I get my
reward no matter whether it works out or
not so okay so so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna I'm gonna write down the bone
a point system and we're gonna just kind
of work out some things on the
whiteboard and so I want to start with
the bone a boy an identity based
encryption system and I'm gonna show you
some so first we're gonna kind of work
now I'm gonna show you some possible
improvement I have for it and then we
can kind of see how it works
okay so it's good to prepare for these
things which sort of did so it's gonna
be a set so we're doing III be right now
is that that's okay great so not HIV for
a second how many people pulling any
more sister well I well how many get was
in the bony avoiding system like okay
creative feel okay so let's say I'm
encrypt so there's gonna be set up I'll
be a little loose with notation and
which we pick on these elements in the
bilinear group you GU and H okay I'm
gonna assume knowing by linear maps
won't get my whole entry so and there's
gonna be of GG to the alpha where this
is the public parameters and the master
secret key will be alpha say good thing
it was Jesus alpha so and also the
master secret key has the public
parameters to write okay so um okay so
what's next alga me want we want an
encryption algorithm right we want to be
able to encrypt M given the public
parameters and ID
I'm also going to define this one
function here of the pub some
define f of I D is equal to anyone or
let's call H of ID they remember this
what's the blown a boy and hash function
yeah so actually I'm gonna use you in
this case yeah so okay so to encrypt I
choose I'm gonna choose a random s and
choose exponent s and I'm gonna have M
times G of G G to the alpha s this is
gonna be my cipher text or I was gonna
call H of ID for a second okay any
questions here I just choose a random
exponent s I take the message am blind I
take e of GG to the alpha raise it to
the s to get this blinding factories I
apply my message by this take G I can
raise it this and I can compute this
function H of ID and I can raise that to
this okay so we agree it's computable
okay now what I want is I want Mikey
Chen kaige n function of aster secret
key and ID okay here I'm going to choose
so so G is of order prime order P okay
I'm please stop me if there's any
confusion on on this and see here marker
okay so we have G to the alpha times H
of let's call this ID killed or
something right maybe it's different to
the s no no to the art
yeah and actually okay so this is this
is how we encrypt this is how we
generate a private key and now for
decryption pretty much we just pair this
part so so really for decryption okay
we're talking about getting the message
m but we really want once you get this
you even invite it out and get the
message m right so really trying to
recover this so we just pair this with
this and that with that and and we end
up getting we end up getting this part
over here so I can so if we do the
parrot so let me just kind of draw it so
that I'm just drawing decryption now
which is e of H of ID comma G RS so here
when we pair this we actually get what
we want we get even G to the Alpha s
from this thing over here so we get what
we want
but we also get this extra junk over
here so we get hash of Summa so if I if
I get hash of identity to the RS care if
this I is equal to wait a second yeah
losta trying to get a of hash of I okay
and if I is equal to if this ID from the
ciphertext is equal to this ID from the
private key we can just divide this out
of here and get what we need okay so any
questions on this any brief okay so this
is this is the bony boring system and I
made this
I made this identity function here all
abstract but if we plug in there how if
we plug in there
hasha look let's just kind of plug it in
to make it a little bit more concrete so
this will be u to the ID h this okay
so and then we'll do the similar thing
over here over here right okay so now
what I want to do is I want to propose a
improved like I want to shave down the
parameter I think we maybe shave down
the parameters just a little bit in the
bone a bone system so I want to propose
a improvement and then see how that goes
okay so what sir yeah so it's okay
in this hash function yes no attack okay
but let's take a look at my improvement
so let's see how it goes
uh-huh so so so suppose okay so so what
I want to do now is I want to shave off
a little bit since this looks a little
extraneous so here's my new hash
function okay
now so so maybe this is the starting
point to the talk I'm going to have here
so any so sort of people and of course
you'll just make the same change the
hash function down there right so what
do people think about this
it's insecure what
okay so so I'm Kent saying is that
suppose ya suppose I have an encryption
for ID and I want to change it into one
for ID Prime
under it under the same message so maybe
I have the private key for ID Prime but
I don't have it for ID so so how can I
do this what would I do
yeah so I raised this whole thing over
here to I D prime over over I D right so
I have the one over idea part here which
which cancels this out and then we
raised it so it's this Mallett this is
malleability attack right and so you're
kind of okay with the yeah okay so so I
get this so I shouldn't be able to take
from ciphertext for message M for a
certain ID and just change it to a
ciphertext or another ID of what I'm
saying and this maybe relates to your
question a little bit like like it yeah
it's it's it's bad to be able to do that
and apparently with my new improvement I
think it's pretty much the same you know
you could try to go to I and actually it
could be any I think okay well so this
is you know maybe the way of looking at
it in the system but I think there's
like a different view that like well we
can take sort of a linear algebra view
of what happened in this attack so the
earlier system we believed was secure or
at least um you know assuming that
there's not a break in the paper that's
been out there for for seven years
and if we think about what's going on
the ciphertext what's really happening
over here so back when we had back when
we had the H in there we can kind of
write what's happening the exponent as a
vector so it's like the scalar s which
is hidden x so it would let's see I D so
this is the U component some writing
this is like the U component here and
the H component was one okay and if I
wanted to change it to and I get one
sample of this right some from the
ciphertext I get one sample of this so
if I want to do an attack I pretty much
have to change this to
I D prime so what I have here is I get
one vector from a dimensional two space
so this is a dimensional space right and
this note there's no scaler there's no
scale or at least it is no scaler let's
say symbolically that I can multiply
this this vector by to get this vector
so I mean ignore the S even like maybe
there's no scale I can multiply assuming
I D is not equal to I D prime right so
this is kind of simple thing so when I
when I did this when I did this I'm
so-called improvement over here well I
kind of so here's my is my improvement
and what I did was I I kind of got rid
of this dimension and then I gave you
that now we had a one dimensional vector
space which I give you one vector from
and I'm not very good at linear algebra
but it means you can span though the
whole the whole space our mathematicians
can confirm confirm this yes okay so so
you see the problem was here was that I
gave out I have in some sense I had I
want to have give out n things and that
mean meant I had to have n plus one at
least n plus 1 dimension subspace ok now
any questions on this is this so we can
kind of see this this problem in just
the IB context if I want to shave things
down a little bit further okay so now is
this okay for me to do this little white
board yeah I thought that's something a
little different right so now let's look
at HIV okay
and so the HIV system yeah
in the Selective security model it was
under decisional bdh although right now
I'm just looking at trying to break
things yeah yeah it's decisional
bilinear diffie-hellman assumption which
okay so now what we can do is so if we
want to look I do a hierarchical IB
let's say up depth to really the boning
so the boning system was actually a
hierarchical ibe scheme and so instead
of having one hash function so for the
first up we have one hash function for
the second level we add a different one
and so we might get something like hash
of yeah a little messy here how does
that go okay so we might get like hash
of let's call this r1 hash of ID one to
the S and this is hash of ID 1 : ID to
the S now let's say that and then if I
want to delegate on oh shoot
okay let's get this out of the way now
let's say if let's say I had ID I'll
just make it simpler here let's say I
had ID 1 over here and I want to
delegate on down to - ID - I just picked
our new r2 so I have oh sorry that's 1
hash - so hash - of ID 1 : ID - so so
I'm kind of I'm doing delegation
dynamically on the board okay so I just
pick our new r2 myself
so so this is Christin delegating to a
group she picks me what she picks a new
r2 and then has G to the r2 over here ok
and the decrypt we can just kind of do
these pairings like we get this a of GG
to the ALF s and then we have two things
we need to cancel here so the
cancellations will come from these two
parts I won't want to try this ok now so
I want to ask a question since since my
first improvement didn't go too well I'm
gonna you have a question I was asking a
question okay what's your question
is it possible to have
of course if you can tell you
but not every decryption key can be used
yeah I think you could do this in a
generic way like likes you're saying
with Kristin's the manager of the group
and I don't want her to be able to
delegate on down anymore yeah so I don't
mean to bring you into every every
example yeah but I could just go to her
level and then like have this no no no
no no like kind of give her knowles all
the way down yeah so you could do any
kind of uh you can do it in a generic
fashion I think yeah so I kind of do
delegate when I give her the key I just
kind of delegate are all the let's
assume there's a bottom which I guess
doesn't happen on down the case but um I
assume there was a bottom I could just
kind of bring her all the way down
well I punt a little bit on that one for
now since it's kind of a little tangent
tangental
okay so now I want to have another
improvement which I saw that so I'm
gonna try to still do this with two
parameters and and here's gonna be my um
here's gonna be my hash functions so
let's let's see if it let's see how
these work so I'm gonna actually replace
these with something concrete so now so
you see I'm now I'm trying to do so
before to two parameters work for HIV of
low well sorry I be of just you know one
level just IB and now I'm trying to do
it with two parameters for so now I'm
trying to do it for level two and in two
parameters okay so a to public permit so
I'm trying to do now let's see so maybe
here I have okay
we'll save that until it actually works
okay so H to the one over ID okay this
would be raised to the s so this is for
level one this is my and then this will
be you to the ID squared times H raised
to the s okay now the question is what
oh so sorry so this is ID one and this
is ID two or iid two concatenated with
whatever it is
so I'm going to take you to the ID one
cubit and H to the one over ID
wellthen the concatenation happens over
here this is ID one - yeah it only has
ID yeah oh say this okay so I'm just
kind of right now yes so I'm not like
like this it's gonna be such a nerd so
ID 1 I should I do okay ID wonka County
with ID 2 squared okay okay so can this
possibly work
pretty comfortable well I have some
complicated looking stuff up here right
but let's kind of look at the two things
let's look at it in the linear algebra
thing right so here I have this victory
at this victus
so I raise you to the ID cubed and then
I have this as 1 over I D here I do want
okay Leo's gonna make me be precise and
then I have another vector which is s to
whatever ID 1 concatenate with ID 2
squared comma 1
okay um well let me see if I can make my
point like okay okay so let's don't
study this too hard it is one hint so
look what's the dimension of this space
here too
how many vectors do I give you two so
what can I do
I can I can span I can span the whole
space again right like if you know name
me any s to that name me any a B and I
could take some linear combinations of
these and give you this for a and B
right
so I mean oh I don't know people think
it like this whole cubing n went over I
I just kind of made this up I didn't
actually think about this I mean we
raise it to the fifth or something I
don't know okay so so don't know that's
what I'm saying don't don't let's let's
not I worry about exec so the point here
is that we have we give away sort of two
vectors and our subspaces that mention
two then we can span it so so I can mall
it to anything I want like give me any
so compute it for a different ID
computer for I compute any ID or two
level ID of your choice with you know
compute the hash functions compute what
they're supposed to be compute the a
part compute the B part and you can use
what's already there to calculate it
okay so that's the point the point isn't
like I just made up this cubing and
raising to the fifth thing or whatever
okay so don't yeah don't study don't
study it too hard okay so so this this
is um so this is the problem the problem
is is that in general like with these
previous systems so the whole point of
this exercise with these previous
systems if I have if I wanted to have
sort of n instances if I want to have n
levels I needed to have n plus 1 size
parameters
okay and some analog of this would be
true in the attribute based encryption
world and this isn't and this isn't such
a good thing be and then the reason for
this is that this global like I'm
getting all these vectors but they're
always to the same s they're not like
individually randomized each time but
there's a reason for this I mean the
reason I reason the same ass is so that
decryption works right because I need to
pair this with s over here and I you
need everything I can't just
I need decryption to work I mean having
a non-functioning system is not a good
option so I can't just you know make up
random you just make up stuff over here
okay so does this give some so maybe
gives you some intuition about why this
problem and this isn't just babbling
boring like all these other systems I've
appeared so far kind of you basically
fall in this category I kind of thought
fall in this type so Josh we have a big
task for you
and oh oh sorry sorry well you have the
experience so yeah okay so and eat well
any questions before it goes down yeah
okay deal late okay and it and this is
kind of what these two suicides said so
well that was my little experimentation
with giving a tark partially on the
right board okay so so these two sides
basically said what I'm not here
contagious I guess so our approach is to
use some type of trying to do a secret
sharing plus fresh randomness for each
level okay so so large public parameters
for large
No
yeah those other bad things that doesn't
do so yes it so now we will okay oh
sorry this a vertex will get a little
larger but not like maybe like a factor
of two larger although there's some
better way to make it like a fact of 1.5
okay so a bit it won't like blow it up
like n cube or something bad like that
okay so our goal is gonna be be able to
do an unbounded system I like I want to
have a constant number of public
parameters hopefully small content like
you know three four or five something
like that of group elements and be able
to go anywhere I want with this with
this with this HIV scheme okay so so
what we kind of do is a Silla mean this
become a high-level picture then maybe
looking at the actual construction will
help a little bit more so they'll be
this kind of master secret which was g2
the alpha for this alpha back here and
for each kind of level or component
we're gonna split this up into many
different pieces that you know should go
well together but then we're gonna kind
of ran them we're gonna randomize each
piece of your key if someone's key so
let's not worry about the delegation for
a second so that they they need to sort
of be unwound amaizing order to tie them
back together and then what we're going
to do is that for the ciphertext will be
for a vector ID Prime and when each
level well this wasn't the best notation
I saw by each level what we're going to
do is and kind of pair them together and
if you know if these if these things
match up right is sort of paint this
brush over it and then we'll then after
you know after the parent or the
decryption we'll be able to put them
back together okay so well let's just
look at the system and hopefully that
will clear things up a little bit okay
so public parameters in the system the
actual description and the paper is
gonna be in like some composite or group
mainly for the reason of the proof but
I'm just going to give it to you the
prime order version to make it a little
simpler so we don't have all these
things flying around okay so we're gonna
have you know five group elements form
the violent tart so I ford the bilinear
group one and our target group so this
is a small constant
we can agree and the master secret key
will be ALP some exponent alpha okay so
now let's look at how decription works
and so let's say we're encrypting to a
vector of length J like I'm going J it
levels deep in my so I should okay I
should be able to go to any depth I want
right there's no bound this is the point
of it being unbounded so pick this s
which is this global s analogous to what
we saw earlier but also this ran this
for each different level which we didn't
see earlier and now unfortunately
there's a place simpler version of this
scheme I wish had time to so this is the
version from the paper so we take a
message m planet by ug g to the alpha s
we kind of saw that before we've just g2
the best part but now what we do is for
each different level from low for level
1 2 all the way to J we sort we have
this w to the S term which is this
global thing but this the main point to
get across here is that we have this
individual randomness on each level and
it at some level it prevents us since
this is Ti is knows this T sub i's
present everywhere this this attack
which we had before of just doing linear
combinations of things on each level
what won't won't happen or we hope it
won't happen I should say okay so there
is something else going on here
so this T sub I is intuitively stopping
us from doing these linear combinations
or at least we hope so but we have to
also hope that decryption works that
it's correct right I'm easy to make a
broken system okay so our T gen we have
this so here's the master authority
doing the key Jen has this random out
pick sorry has this alpha which is from
the master secret key and splits it up
into j j so assume the levels are the
same so let's put some two lambda 1 to
lambda J such that this sum of all them
is equal to alpha because this is this
secret splitting and also chooses ransom
to random two variables randomly for
each level and again I'm doing I'm gonna
try to like foot focus on kind of the
part okay and then what we have is for
each level so kind of each level will
have a piece of alpha and
and you know if you have all these
pieces we can literally combine to get
alpha and then there's something
dependent upon the identity at each
level okay and but interesting thing
here even though we kind of said well
the bonilla boring thing doesn't work
for this on this kind of remnants it's
almost like we kind of do this scheme
locally we kind of almost put put push
it back a little bit further like like
there this does look like the bone a
boring HIV scheme at each different
level we almost you can imagine like
instead of T of I so before you had this
global variable s and now we're almost
doing this HIV thing locally at each
level so okay let me so this is just
what I talked about before but let's
kind of look at how things might work
for decryption okay so we have m and e
GG to alpha s so we're going to get ug g
to the alpha s so one way to get a of G
G to the FS is if we just recovery of G
G to the lambda I times s for each for
each I because then when we multiply all
these together all the lambdas sum
together which sums to alpha so we're
gonna this is going to be our sub R sub
task over here okay so so one way
towards getting to it is that so I'm
just showing you a pieces I'm not
showing all the cipher texts Enki is if
we pair this together
and then pair this together and then
divide them out so this component pair
with this component will cancel out here
so so so this will give you a of G W to
the s times y I and so what we're left
with is something that gives us what we
want over here and something else that
we need to cancel so we need we get what
we want over here and then we need to
cancel but in order to recover it we
need to cancel out this part okay so
this is some local thing and now this
this part over here is actually canceled
out in the similar to the bone a bone
like way or Canady hello V cats like way
with this local thing okay so here's
gonna so here's like a little more
detailed pretty much what we're going to
see is that the theme of this is that
we'll get what we want we'll get
something we want but it's going to be
multiplied by something that we don't
want to we want to get rid of and we're
going to want to get that thing to get
rid of it but then when we go for that
we're going to get it but then get
another thing it's going to be this kind
of long this kind of long chain of
things but but you know it will
terminate which is good okay so so our
first goal is to recover eg to the alpha
s right because we want this to get the
message okay so we and then we can do
this we can get a new sub goal of
recovering each of these a of G to the
lambda I times s um please ask me a
question if there's like any point here
okay so we can do this by by pairing
these two things together so we get the
s in the lambda I part here but then we
get this extra junk so we get the part
we want then we get the sex junk so now
I have a new goal right I want to get
this thing over here okay and then okay
but then we can't get it by pairing this
with this but again we so we kind of get
this thing that we need over here but
now we got that thing and so I'm sorry
that this chain is is a little long here
but then at the finally at the end what
we can actually get this part with all
these cancellations I should mention
that there's a slightly simpler version
so I almost wish I was able to write up
is a slightly simpler version of this
scheme which um which has one less one
less thing on the chain is a little bit
easier to understand I can show some
people to people on paper afterwards if
you're interested but yeah we sort of
the proof for this one worked out a
little bit better I'm so like okay I
just want to mention that key delegation
is pretty like we want to be able to do
delegation that's pretty easy so before
we had it at J levels and now we want to
go to jail US one level so you just pick
this Omega 1 through Omega J plus 1 that
sum to zero and you kind of reran demise
the key so you kind of tag on this extra
parts of the key on you and then you
reran demise it so this isn't too much
different I mean it's accommodated for
the system it's not too much too novel
compared to what was done before
okay and you didn't you have to also
read so you have to reran demise so
there was a yes this question earlier if
the keys were distributed the same those
you Brian okay so in this system we do
distribute the keys the same in both
ways you can probably improve the
efficiency a little bit of delegation by
not doing it that way but then your
proof becomes harder okay so how are we
doing on time Kristin like should i okay
I want to torture people that long yeah
yes so so okay so wrap it up in yeah
okay that'll be fine um okay so what I
want okay so I'm Ken it's for compositor
but I presented you the prime order
thing you could do prime order in the
generic group model over some not so
awesome thing you know I think someone
else not nummies actually converted so
most of these composite order group
things the point is to get these
subspaces where the and you can
translate it to prime order groups but
make me be I'll take okay so so this
this is the system so um so before I go
on to just discuss like at a high level
of proof any questions on the system so
kind of the challenges that you want
this you you want this global variable
in the ciphertext to tie everything
together you know it has to decrypt at
the end of the day but we saw the
spanning problem with the vectors so the
technical challenge was how do we kind
of randomized each level but still let
things come so we don't want things to
combine in the bad way this is that a
lot of the script okay we want things to
combine in the way we don't want where
we're changing all these vectors but but
we do want things but we do want things
to decrypt at the end so kind that the
trick was to get this kind of randomized
each level locally but still in a way
that allows you to combine at the end
all their buddies essentially share the
secret to make policies that are more
restrictive yeah is that and that's very
similar the fundamental differences this
is a HIV is a subset of a be with
delegation the other techniques well
briefly is discussed the a B thing yeah
the techniques are similar in some ways
a HIV is just kind of pedagogically
easier to do to talk about right now but
yeah I think a B with delegation is more
powerful okay so I'm just gonna um so
this one so I'll go yes so the hardest
assumption for this is some of these
composite order group assumptions but I
will mention that people have been able
to take all these systems building these
assumptions people have in the past
found analogues in the linear assumption
and someone it's not me but someone else
has already done this so so this is with
some some of these subgroup like maybe
through these sub group type assumptions
but I don't know like I kind of know
this privately so I'm not sure how much
I could share but but someone else has
done this in the linear assumption so
you through a lot of terms there so look
like
Kuehl sdh they closed it there's no
queue you just know if you're yeah yeah
yeah in the prime myrtle group there is
a prime it's not that exact system i
showed you but there's kind of a vert
version of it
someone else has under deal in and for
that in my paper it's not q anything
it's a couple it's like three
assumptions in composite order groups
but there are static assumptions they
don't have this they don't depend on Q
oh I stopped giving them names so they
fall within some class different sub
group type assumptions I can show you
offline a little bit if you're
interested but there's probably no
efficient way to communicate them right
now
but uh okay it kind of the point is I
think I think people well okay so now
that now that you know and I'm on this
um in some sense I see I see this stuff
happening in into there's kind of two
different ways to do these things if you
do them with composite order groups you
can usually easily get them without a
queue type assumption but then the
actual assumption looks a little messy
and some people go oh my gosh it's it's
kind of confusing it's messy but then
there's the second phase which is
translate you know well why did I do
with composite order groups well because
I needed these subspaces and it's
cleaner and easier to do with subgroups
and then you can kind of so this is kind
of where you can develop the main
concepts this is my own view of things
and then there's this kind of mechanical
part where you can take these concepts
and then translate them to prime order
groups and get it under this this like a
decision linear assumption which is a
better assumption than all the ones we
work with and actually I say my student
Allison has been looking at all you know
automating this and it's you know it's
best not to have to do it you like a
quick way to do it but in the past all
these things have been translated over
so if you name me any composite or a
scheme Mike I can tell you it's been
translated or I think I can tell you
it's been translated or Hatt has been
translated over
so so if it's static we're going to
little let me just let me get back to
that like a little on a tangent here but
maybe I'm maybe that's best offline okay
so I just want to give you a little
overview of how the proof goes so so the
challenges here are that if you want to
do a partition what was called a
partitioning type proof these things
they always relied on you if I had like
the child ciphertext a vector of length
10 I had a program in these ten levels
of identity into the public parameters
well or 15 or whatever and now my public
parameters are only of size five or some
small constant so these partitioning
proofs don't look like they all work
here so that's problem but even with
dual system proof this kind of low
instrument they kind of depend on what
I'll call entropy to avoid some-some
paradox and they kind of always depended
on the parameters being pretty big so it
wasn't even obvious how to do it with
these these proofs but it turned out we
were able to do this with dual system
encryption and let's see I'm almost
let's see so I'll give a quick overview
of dual system encryption and but maybe
in the talk there and people can ssme
questions offline ok so actually you
know I'll just skip a couple of these
slides here because I probably only have
sorry this is this whiteboard thing I
didn't know how long it would take so if
you interested in dual system encryption
you can talk to me offline but so let me
just conclude by saying ok so we did
have this original motivation for a
hierarchical ibe um but ok we could
maybe argue this point a little bit you
might be able to say like well geez what
if you just made them of depth 30 no no
maybe people won't go depth below 30 I'm
not sure if that's actually true or not
where I think it gets much more
motivating is an attribute based
encryption where for example the
ciphertext is pig with some metadata
like attributes and I use this key is
which you know which describing which
ciphertext it's allowed to decrypt so in
the past what I've had to do is
the public parameters would give a bound
of how many attributes would describe
something and there it's a little hard
to say well what should this bound be
you know you could have some time
variable you might come up with you know
there could be some very short site some
with you know very short ones and then
you know maybe every once while there's
a few that grows a few hundred well now
everyone needs to pay the price for this
moreover till I compute these hash
functions actually if you make your
public parameters of size and it's
actually n square you need n
exponentiations for computing this hash
function each time so actually on the
performance really hurts you um much
more than even in the Hib case okay so
let's so this is kind of more motivating
thing to me and I'll just say we were
able to extend this to attribute based
encryption a lot of the kind of made it
if fall is pretty it follows reasonably
easily so before this HIV you know we
split up this alpha into the secret
lambda 1 plus lambda 2 plus lambda 3
plus lambda J is equal to alpha here
here we mainly just we have a boolean
formula or like a secret sharing scheme
associated with the policy we just
reflect that secret sharing over there
okay and it turns out kind of the weird
thing is even though we do with dual
system encryption proofs which is
supposed to be good for adaptive
security and we were only able to get
selective in this case for a reason I
can so in the HIV we were able to get
adaptive security um we had to sort of
go back to selective security for the
attribute encryption world which was a
little funny in some ways but it for a
technical reason but anyway so this is
where I think like kind of where the
motivation really helps out because I
just have pretty much the same size very
small parameters and you know I like
kind of weighed publish my system I
don't have to commit myself to how many
attributes I I need
we would need to understand we need to
go deeper into the proof in order to
explain the technical so I'm happy to
talk about it offline it probably the
amount of time you can't do it okay so
any questions
well okay you didn't get what I meant
okay well so this ciphertext is pegged
with two attributes right so what's the
maximum number of attributes you can you
can tag to a ciphertext
well so a reference the Goyal Pandey so
how is that the Pandey paper so it if
you want to if you have public
parameters of size four or something
can you tag in twenty attributes in your
work
yeah but it's the same spanning problem
as we remember we had this like kind of
weird hash function and and that was a
very slow
yeah yeah but even this small yeah this
small universe the public parameters are
exactly equal to the number of matches
so yeah so so it's in your own work that
the limitation is as present
we had sub I and the number of eyes was
the number of shares of the secret right
so that wasn't the size of the public
parameters should I go back to the site
okay my basic question is whether like
what was the purpose
secret sharing was that what was giving
you the unbounded that you could give it
keep going level after level and you
just leave increase the number of shares
and secret
oh okay so let's bring up the system so
maybe I'll I'm so J's the level but
notice the public parameters are here
yeah it does that that that does go at
the level yes which is the same as
previous system they can go to the penny
yes so so the ciphertext size does grow
with the number of I mean so one
question is can you do this with a
compact ciphertext but so this kind of
matches what was what was done with
previous like in the bone a boring
system for example the cipher text size
grew with with with the number of
loveless it's just I can pick any when
I'm encrypting I can pick any J I want
right the public parameters don't
there's nothing the public parameters
that dictates me to me how far I need to
go it is the case that it does grow
linearly with J but there's nothing in
the public forum Ria's which specifies
like maximum Jake
so that must have come out somewhere in
the proof that you showed us
like the calculation
to cancel or not or whatever that you
mean this this part here yeah having
trouble understanding the mapping of
secret sharing scheme to the what you
showed us it quite follow the details
like sure these supposed to be like
independent secrets that are given at
each level like if you're the person
that's delegated down J levels you're
gonna get all of these guys well you'll
get them in the exponent over here yeah
um so know that me if I give him to you
in the clarity good great so here's a so
let me first say they had this other
question yeah I didn't so I kind of took
Allison sighs and modified them a little
bit I the secret sharing part isn't
really than not the secret sharing was
kind of done before in the previous
systems more or less or another thing
it's kind of more this M it's part of it
but it's kind of more this structure of
the ciphertext which is more the novelty
and this local cancellation but okay so
so I'm making a key for you right I'm
gonna make my key let's say you're at
depth five okay so okay so the authority
what it does is it chooses lambda 1
lambda 2 lambda 3 lambda 4 all the way
to lambda 5 s such that they summed
alpha and I just and I give you the key
of this according to this algorithm no I
don't give ya that's the master secret
key I I don't
yeah I shouldn't give you alpha okay and
you get you only I don't even give you
the lambdas I just give you them
but normally Keys you think of them as
being random and here you've got them
they're related right there
you took like say but one instance would
be like lambda five would be one more
than lambda five in another instance and
when the floor was one okay no but
here's how I do I choose lambda one
randomly I lose choose around lambda two
roundly lambda three four randomly and I
set lambda five to be alpha - yeah
they're not completely random but but if
they were completely random anyone could
make a private key like they have to tie
together somehow you want decryption you
want these things to like relate if they
don't relate to alpha in any way they're
like completely random group elements
then
well let me know it was so is it secret
sharing and the sense that like when you
just not do that decryption calculation
that it looks like a super sharing thing
or what why you call it series sure um
it's like an N out of n secret sharing
so pretty much so in an HIV I'm saying
you have to match at level one you have
to and you have to match it level two
and Jeff will match at level 3 and level
4 and level 5 so basically I'm taking
the secret as part of the I'm basically
executing I'm sharing the secret halfa
into these exponents and I'm embedding
them in the AV system if I have some
policy of like you know attribute A or B
and C I'll share it I'll do secret
pretty much that I mean the a true based
encryption system is just really the
same thing except for we share alpha
like according to some some Paulson
ling'er your secret sharing scheme that
represents a policy but I'll just remark
that on this idea that alpha is in bed
like in all these previous systems like
the bone a boy and when alpha is
embedded in the key so so at no point do
you have private keys which are
completely random right like I mean if
we if we lift it up the screen again
we'll go and see the bone a coin system
has alpha bedded in it
so I wouldn't I wouldn't sit I wouldn't
say the fact that alpha is embedded
someone here it is is is a strange thing
yeah you have to make the security proof
go through but if it wasn't embedded in
there I'd be scared because like when
the heck is alpha doom if you know like
these things should all be reflected
crickets Karl and Leo this is a much
less technical question well so you've
been using these example cycle Kristin
and during
the delegation chief ends so it's been
something of a disappointment with
public key infrastructure the delegation
changed certainly not very long yeah
part of the reason for that is that if
you go down and do all the registration
or any kinds of things you would be
gene basically when you go climbing back
to another place the trust relationship
would be very weak and so having a depth
of Gina
to imagine that anyone anywhere else in
the tree would trust something at that
local level of service registration so
having a very great depth of tree it's
not very likely if that's the type of
thing I just want to understand if I
could reconcile that with
the need to have Africans so having a
hundred attributes is not at all that
impossible that's that's right very well
happen and so you know understand a
little better this relationship between
the depth of the tree and the size of
the future
so so I think during the middle of my
talk I did say like well I think the
moat for reason similar what you're
giving here I said the motivation is
stronger in a B well okay um actually
can I grab some white board I mean in
some sense this HIV it's almost like an
and sorry Josh me too
this is almost like an an policy it's
like you meet you you match at level one
it's like you match at level one and
level two and level three if you forget
about the delegation for a second it's
almost like you have to match at level
one and level two and level three and
level 4 and level five this one big so
what a B is it okay so that's just an
policies so a B is just sort of like
well we have better than an we have any
boolean formula so it's just turn so
it's kind of like how yes how many
different attributes so how many
different so when you're in the
ciphertext you for HIV you kind of give
something out for each different level
and an attribute basic encryption give
out something for each different
attribute the techniques are very
similar I use HIV because it's it's it's
a simpler thing for pedagogical reasons
to give in the talk but once you
understand the HIV thing getting the
attribute encryption is like very small
step
yes it's yeah I know that it's a little
yeah there's a little bit of a that's
maybe a little bit of a false connection
it's like it's like it turns out I have
to give like a component of the site an
HIV have to give a component we just
kind of counting components of the
ciphertext so for each level in HIV I
happen to give out have to give out
something for each component of the
ciphertext I have to give out something
and then for in a true basic encryption
for each kind of attribute I have have
to give out a component of the
ciphertext so it's yeah yes so yeah I
could see how you might hold depth of H
I yeah this is kind of you know maybe
that leaves you a little bit
which which boolean formulas to be
supportive like a very deep nested and
any boolean formula and the cause this
the okay so there's kind of two
different versions of a be a this focus
on the key policy one basically the so
think of the number of nodes leaves in
the boolean formula the or the size of
the boolean formula there's like a group
element or two group whatever couple
group elements for every in the private
key for this sorry besides the private
key grows linearly with the size of the
building
and what I before me write it or dismiss
link and then CNF good and whatever form
you write it so if you can find a good
representation that's it's good if you
find if you find a really bad
representation it's equally bad and
that's pretty much the same in all these
a B systems
anything else
all right